[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde que eu me entende por gente
eu tinha um incômodo que eu não sabia
que era mas era como do forte assim de
situações mais sérias na minha vida mas
aí é outro pad e situações mais
corriqueiras do tipo eu tinha que
explicar para o meu pai que eu não
precisava casar pra eu sair de casa eu
podia sair de casa e trabalhar me
sustentar
eu me vi numa situação às vezes de
querer mudar minha personalidade que é
como vocês podem ver sim meu ex namorado
porque ele falava que eu tinha muito
amigo homem e que pegava muito bom ficar
abraçando esses amigos e eu me
questionava cara será não não está certo
isso e esse incômodo eu tava ali comigo
toda semana encontrava com ele uma
situação x y e assim como do sabiá
apelidava ele esteve presente comigo a
vida inteira mas aí eu é bem aos 25 anos
engravidei solteira
aí esse incômodo falou assim oi está
aqui agora na sua vida todos os dias a
toda hora querida toda hora você vai
lembrar que existem não sabe que era né
mas a engravidar e está solteira sem um
companheiro seu namorado
parece que incomodei
eu comecei a incomodar as pessoas eu
comecei a sair na rua para executada com
abacaxi de glee tem na cabeça eu estava
grávida e ao tentarem pra mim e o pai o
seu namorado fábio não não tenho
namorado a se separar ou não
era realmente algo e aí a mãe grávida
fui perguntar por outras mulheres né
também passar por isso esses sintomas e
ao descrever os sintomas e descobrir que
chamava machismo é isso aí na minha vida
ok vamos lá machismo machismo né porque
eu estava vivendo machismo porque eu
tinha virado manhã a partir do momento
que a barriga começou a crescer
eu já era identificada como uma mãe mas
eu não estava cumprindo um papel social
de manhã um papel pré determinado por
isso comenta começou a incomodar tanto
mas esse perguntou é determinado por
quem quem predeterminou esse papel de
uma mulher mãe não foi uma mulher não
foi uma mãe foi um homem e foi o
patriarcado como a senhora patriarcado
thai bomba ter arcado tá ele existe às
vezes não sabe o nome dele mas a nossa
sociedade é patriarcal
as grandes empresas são na maioria
coordenadas por homens
a política do nosso país é decidida em
sua grande maioria por homens
uma casa também onde um homem decide e
coloca as regras para sua esposa por
seus filhos também é patriarcal e foi
esse patriarcado lá de antigamente que é
outro pede que o título aqui mãe tinha
que está casada e mãe era isso mantinha
que ser muito boa muito perfeita cuidar
dos filhos que martin instinto materno é
que mãe ele nasceu bebé ela eo bebê bebê
e ela só eles dois porque isso é que é
ser mãe
isso é lindo né esse amor que se não
fosse no amor não e aí eu falei nossa tá
bom tá eu estava grávida e depois aquele
susto daquele teste de gravidez quando
estava grávida falei mas só eu quero ser
mãe e eu decidi ser mãe mas eu não tinha
idéia do que era ser mãe
eu não sabia pra mim mãe era tarde
gisele built-in né que estava
amamentando fazendo e fazendo o cabelo
sendo maquiado fahey quero semana
ou era hit the friends que era mãe
solteira eu falei que nem eu e foi ótimo
e estavam todos os amigos com ela ea
vida dela estava lindo e depois que que
a ema nasceu né
era a mãe da novela era a mãe dos filmes
é a mãe da revista voi
quero ser mãe é que aconteceu isso na
semana né
a mídia me enganou ninguém ensinou que
quero é ser mãe
na minha escola teve dia das mães todo
ano eu não faltei a nenhum e eu não
tinha projeto que quer ser mãe eu fiz
duas faculdades
ninguém falou sobre maternidade la roque
ao me tornar mãe eu percebi que eu tinha
escolhido ser uma pessoa que não existia
eu não sabia que ser mãe é ter que lutar
pra você conseguir pare com respeito
para você não ser enganado até por um
médico que é uma pessoa que tinha
confiar porque esse médico pode ser que
ele faça o quê com que você quer uma
cesárea desnecessária porque só de 10 a
15 por cento necessários no mundo são
necessárias
então quando você vira mãe seja tem que
estudar a política o sistema de saúde do
brasil estudar sobre o pato porque você
vai ser enganada eu não sabia que você
mãe é você e fazer o parto e fazer um
corte você é tão grande que talvez você
demore um ano ou mais para sentir prazer
relação sexual de novo semana é você e
pare e não poder gritar ou não ter um
acompanhante e net ridicularizarem por
que você fez e foi bom na hora né porque
está gritando agora
um parto né semana é ter que o filho com
quatro cinco meses sair de casa e passar
de mais 10 horas fora de casa porque a
sua licença-maternidade acabou ou é tê e
poder contar com o pai do seu filho mas
a licença paternidade de 20 dias da
semana em solo às vezes é escutar que
você tem muita sorte que o pai de seu
filho paga pensão porque tem pai que nem
isso então que bom né
que ótimo que se encaixando bom ou é ser
mãe e ser solteira e as pessoas acharem
que seu maior objetivo de vida é achar o
marido que vai se tornar o pai do seu
filho mas que pra isso você tem que ser
vaidosa tem que emagrecer tem que se
cuidar mas se vai achar o que é isso
você virou mãe você é solteira vir os
objetivos e nem cria o filho não vai
achar um marido
aí o objetivo é ser mãe é contar com a
ajuda às vezes dos avós do x ec julgada
pelos próprios avós e tios ou seja
julgada por quem por outras mães
sabe aquela história aí teve filho pô eu
pago ao criar o que é isso né
é isso eu tinha virado manhã não sabia
que semana tudo isso como eu fiquei
perdida excluída oprimida eu nos
primeiros dias do caetano as pessoas vão
visitar e como é que você tá eu falava
que eu estava bem mas eu queria falar
não tenho me dado que eu tô fazendo
nunca fiz isso
mas o instinto materno não tinha que
saber fazer o que era aquilo
sinto uma tela ensina a gente cuidar do
filho né amamentar se pode falar
instinto materno é assim apegue assim
olha boquinha olha que tem que ver tem
que massagear se não dá né instinto
materno que ensinou pra gente não foi
não foi na gente mas a então tinha
virado mãe
e tinha caído numa cilada e eu me sentir
sozinha no mundo
eu senti que se eu falasse a verdade
sobre ser mãe
as pessoas as pessoas vão me julgar que
eu amava meu filho eu me senti tão mal
que eu desenvolvi uma depressão pós
parto e até isso eu tinha que fazer eu
tinha que falar estou com depressão as
pessoas olhavam com caetano assim falam
mas eu amo ele tá tudo bem é de pressão
eu amo meu filho mas aquela mídia lá que
ensinou pra gente que ser mãe é a mãe
perfeita também ensinou pessoal que
depressão pós-parto ea mãe que joga o
fim da janela
então eu falava que estava tinha
depressão pós-parto que a maioria das
mulheres tem muitas mulheres têm mas nem
eu podia falar que são as pessoas
achavam que o cartão estava roxo ou
passando fome então tinha que falar eu
tinha que dar explicação eu parei de
falar eu fui ficando influenciada e aí
olhava pra cá e e fava gente como eu amo
essa pessoa né
ele lá crescendo a gente criando um
vínculo tinha dia que eu tava dez horas
da noite com a camisola e jada com sutiã
para fora de amamentação e aí ele dormir
tudo que eu queria que ele dormisse
quando ele dormiu não colocava no berço
e ficava olhando pra ele porque é uma
lei
eu falo careceu mulher melhor momento do
meu dia
olha esse menino que eu fiz eu sou muito
que isso e eu parava para pensar
falava como é que eu vivi até hoje se
essa pessoa não sei minha vida não tinha
sentido em um herói mas espera aí sim
gente eu amava caetano loucamente o que
odiava é ser mãe
a mãe do patriarcado aí estão pensando
nossa então a helen ela né pariu
já sandro feminista radical claro que
não é nem sabia que tinha feminismo
eu tinha aliás eu tinha preconceito
terríveis sobre feminismo que eu tenho
vergonha de falar
mas ao saber que eu ia que estava
revoltado com tudo aquilo que eu não
podia falar sobre aquilo eu descobri que
quem sabe se estudasse o feminismo e
poder lutar contra o machismo e eu
comecei a estudar tirei meu preconceito
e ignorância
comecei a estudar comecei a me formar
comecei a conversar com amigos
feministas e falei cara olha que o
patriarcado fez ele fez o que chegou e
falou assim olha gente pra você mãe você
tem que fazer tudo sozinha porque mãe
boa essa você tem que cuidar do seu
filho sozinha você tem que abdicar das
coisas porque afinal você se tornou mãe
isso é que é amor
então o que ele fez ele fez com que eu
ficasse cansado exausto que porque eu
saísse do mercado de trabalho com que eu
parasse de saber de situações políticas
no país
ele excluiu de decisões
ele excluiu do mercado de trabalho ele
continuou como homem ali no poder
excluindo uma mulher eu falei errar aqui
não
você vai ver que não é assim então por
que que é importante diz romantizar a
maternidade gente quando a gente
romantismo maternidade
a gente explica que a gente defende que
não que o filho não há uma
responsabilidade só de uma mulher é
necessário uma vida inteira para se
educar uma criança tem um provérbio
africano porque porque criança é filho
da mãe e filho do pai e filho dos avós é
filho do xf dos vizinhos porque quando
essa criança criada por todo o mundo uma
mãe pode sim voltar a reivindicar o seu
papel na sociedade e quando várias
pessoas participam de uma criação de um
filho é muito mais fácil mudanças
políticas acontecerem do que sua mãe
reivindicando é importante de romantizar
a maternidade para que uma mulher não
entre
se tinha emprego possa ser sincero e
falar que ela pretende ter filho alguma
hora e que mesmo assim ela consiga
aquela vaga o que uma mulher fale tem o
filho 123456 quando eu quiser isso não
influi no meu profissionalismo é
importante de romantizar maternidade
para que uma mãe que está sentindo
sozinha possa sair de casa e o ônibus
que ela pega o metrô seja um local
seguro para ela e para o bebê o que não
é
então não sai de casa ou para que uma
mãe possam andar na rua na calçada com
um carrinho e ela não esteja fazendo uma
prova de rally cross fit
ela só esteja passeando com o filho dela
para que uma mãe possa participar da
cultura da cidade dela possa e para
restaurantes para que as crianças sejam
bem vindas e que nesses locais têm um
trocador
pelo menos isso né
é importante de romantizar maternidade
gente porque a gente não pode mais fazer
esse papel de dar nosso suor do nosso
sangue ser excluída da sociedade criar
um cidadão economicamente ativa pea e
participar desse capitalismo entendeu a
gente tem que participar junto a gente
tem que reivindicar nosso lugar
quando você diz romantismo maternidade
você muda o mundo produz seus filhos
você muda o mundo pro mundo melhor ea
desumanização da maternidade é feminista
[Aplausos]